so this year I started a network
and what the network is is it kind of
like the way I saw it was sort of like a
TV network but on YouTube where we have
different shows that we host and
different I'm just a really creative
person so it's funny I never really look
at work as working I mean like
occasionally I do but to me I'm just
having a good time this is just like a
fun hobby that panned out
sorry guys
um so
um
now we're looking to sign talents now I
have one signed Talent right now I've
signed people in the past sometimes it
worked out sometimes it didn't
um Christine now does you know
she's a young she's a 22 year old chick
blonde she had this whole series idea
called debunking The Loon to see where
she does these essay videos debunking
stuff so
I've recently started looking at other
talents to sign and I've had a lot of
people apply to me
now guys the issue I'm getting is you
guys keep applying with the same exact
show that I do
so you'll be like Pearl I want to do a
show where we bring in people and talk
about relationships I'm like well
guys that's the exact same thing so my
first priority right now is to sign
people in London so
um essentially one girl came in and said
she's a lawyer so she could break down
cases and stuff from like a legal point
of view
I thought that was amazing I thought
that was great
I thought it was an amazing idea
so I said okay
um well nothing signed but we're gonna
we're gonna test her out right or people
like I had one person come in and say I
want to do a show about dads
well it's not a bad idea but like what's
the
like I need there has to be some sort of
conflict right
and it could be a competition that could
be the conflict it could be a battle of
ideas whatever it is
um but a lot of you keep pitching like
the same thing that I do and that's not
really gonna work
um so what am I looking forward to
Talent um someone
yeah that has a unique idea for a show
um that is a self-starter so a hard
worker and they have like original ideas
of things that they can do
[Music]
um
yeah I think that's like pretty much you
know and they have it's a unique show
that we don't really see on YouTube so
um a couple ideas I had I was like we
could do a live debate panel which I
know they're they're shows like that but
you can just do it bigger better here
right
um and ideally that person's in London
and can work five days a week it's a
full-time job so
let me know what you guys think in the
in the comments like the video
um and let me know any other questions
you have about being assigned Talent
um ideally you'd be in the midwest or
Vegas LA area but we're open to other
ones so you know let me know guys see ya
bye-bye